what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves I
my sincere hope is that if you see in
you what I see in you you'll be able to
change the planet so to help you on your
journey today I'm going to talk about
seven ways to be more disciplined so
staying disciplined staying focused
staying on task is one of the hardest
things for especially creative
entrepreneurs to do because we have all
these things that we want to do when
we're in our head and dreaming and
vision but then we actually have to do
the work and be disciplined about it so
thought I'd share with you my seven tips
on how to be successful doing it tip
number one is create a morning routine
you have to start off right
so many times it happens entrepreneurs
and it happened to me so many multiple
times you get inspired randomly I would
get inspired randomly I would meet
somebody at for coffee and we'd be
bubbling ideas and I get so inspired and
go home and work or listen to a YouTube
video or read a book or something that
would just fire me up and I'd be working
like crazy and then the next day we'll
wake up and like poof looks like it's
gone I'm starting over from scratch I
felt like I start over from scratch and
I still do I feel like I start from
scratch every single day the baseline
becomes maybe a little bit higher over
time but I'm still starting off from
scratch I don't wake up energized
passionate ready to go attack the day
you know that's not me at least maybe
that's you maybe that's some people if
that's you you're probably watching this
video but I think most people wake up
starting from scratch I think we put on
this entrepreneur mask if you like yeah
I'm hosting hard I'm grinding but we
wake up and we're not we're not grinding
we're not we're not super motivated
something we hate our life but we know
it could be working harder I think you
need a daily reset and it's figuring out
what is the one thing that gets you
inspired that gets you passionate it
gets you motivated to get you the only
price it's like I want to go do
something today you've all felt that
feeling before I know what it is for me
for me a lot of times it's it's the
videos it's watching successful people
having success but that's what I want to
do
and seeing it on a regular basis makes
me want to do it so I made the channel
selfishly for myself to like the top ten
in the men to me all those is for me I
want to see it I want to get motivated I
want to be inspired I want to learn
knowledge yes but just seeing people
doing great things makes me want to do
great things so that's what helps me so
to start your day with it it's why I did
the end special seriously start your day
with a shot of an espresso to get you
going but if that's not your thing I
guess cool you'd have to watch my
channel I get it read a book
meet with a friend you know listen to a
podcast whatever the thing is there's no
judgment you know like playing with your
ring gets you excited or waxing your
eyebrows or whatever it is like it
doesn't matter whatever the thing is
that ditch you looks wrong this day is
going to be great do that every day
start your day with it because if you
start your day off on the wrong foot or
you start your day off just falling into
your schedule you may not be inspired
the whole day or you may randomly come
across something at four o'clock that
day and then that's what gets you all
motivated but you've lost from when you
wake up the four o'clock right there's a
lot of time in there that could have
been way more productive focusing on
important things and so find the thing
that gets you motivated they get to
energize and start your day with it
every single day tip number two is
create a regular schedule I think it's
way easier to be disciplined when you
have a schedule that you are following
one of the hardest things I think for
entrepreneurs is we have to balance this
thing if we want creative freedom we
want creative expression want to be able
to do what we want to do but also we
need to have some kind of routine some
kind of discipline because left to our
own means we may not wake up and do
anything on that day or at least
anything of substance or values it's
easy to get distracted by other things
and it's not furthering our goals and so
what I find really helps for me is I
create a regular schedule
and every day I kind of know what I'm
doing and I chunk my time some mondays
are one thing and Jude is another thing
and Wen's is another thing and so on for
the rest of the week and when I wake up
on a Monday morning I don't have to
think about what I'm doing today it's
already there it's on my list I have my
tasks I know what I'm doing Monday I
start with a great you know morning
ritual and then I
into my day right and I think that helps
most of the time I think on the rare
occasion that you feel inspired by
something else like I wake up and I want
to really want to go off and do that
I'll often go out and do that and cancel
everything else that I was working on
for that day because chances are what I
create in that moment is going to be
gold like when you're in the flow and
you're really feeling some pain what's
going to come out of that is going to be
golden the challenge is you're not in
the flow every day at least me I'm not
in flow every day I don't wake up and
flow I'm just like a whole day of flow
and I'm ready to go That's not me
that you great ignore this point but
most people don't wake up and just slow
the whole day and so I had the routine
for when videos most of my days and then
when I'm in flow I go and follow that
passion at the same time when I feel
like my something's missing or feel like
I want to add something else to my
schedule I mean something else has to be
pulled out and so whenever I feel like
the work that I'm doing in my calendar
is not matching up to what I want to do
I have a vision I have dreams I have
other interests I want to pursue then I
start to change my schedule so the
schedule is what I live by it's what I
wake up and do on most days and if I
know it's in my schedule it's going to
get done super important because what's
my own devices I would still be
productive but nowhere near as
productive nor near as disciplined and
so knowing what you're going to do when
you wake up but not having to make
choices on the side every single time
makes life a lot easier tip number three
is track your progress there's a famous
expression that what gets measured gets
done or gets accomplished when you are
tracking what you're doing you're more
likely to pay attention to it and want
to fix it and so you know if your goal
is to lose weight if you're tracking
your weight every day and you're
tracking your calories every day you're
much more likely to lose weight you know
if your goal is to call 10 customers a
day or reach out to ten people a day or
you know make a YouTube video every week
if you are tracking it then you're more
likely to follow through on it just like
when you're making gold the more
specific you are the more likely you're
going to hit it if your goal is to just
lose weight then you're unlikely to do
it but if your goal is to lose 10 pounds
or 20 pounds your goal is to hit you
know 50 thousand dollars and more Rev
you or whatever your goal is you're more
likely to hit it because you're being
specific and so if you're tracking it on
a daily basis or weekly basis then you
want to hit those numbers you know when
I'm working out with my personal trainer
you know he gives me gold underneath the
hit yeah I need to hit nine hundred
calories a week in cardio as an example
right now so I have to do 45 minutes in
two chunks 45 minutes in 45 minutes on
the on the machine and I'm you show on
social media is you guys can check me
out there when I'm answering your
questions would I do 45 minutes without
him maybe maybe I do 15 minutes so
here's a guy okay do some cardio right
but if you're tracking it and you know
it's happening and you make a
spreadsheet or use a checklist or
whatever it is how you want to track
don't get caught up in the tools the
tools don't matter it could be a piece
of paper and a pen when you're checking
something off and you know you've got it
done you're much more likely to follow
through what gets tracked gets done so
anything you want to stay disciplined on
have some kind of tracking system in
place email or Evernote or a CRM or a
calendar anything something just so that
you're attracting it consistently tip
number four is commit to somebody else
when you commit to somebody else you're
much more likely to follow through the
reason is we will let other people down
less than we'll let ourselves down it's
easy to let ourselves down how many
times do we say I'm going to do
something but then you don't do it
you're letting yourself down right
constantly you would for you guys who
snooze I wouldn't talk about that yet
it's not on my list but let's go here
now don't snooze stop hitting the snooze
button the thing that happens when you
hit the snooze button is I'm going to
wake up at 8:00 a.m. or I'm going to
wake up at 7:00 a.m. and the first thing
you do is say that goal is not important
to me
that's not going to happen the first
thing you do every morning if you hit
the snooze button is let yourself down
that's how you start your day and if you
hit the snooze button five times you
start your day every day by letting
yourself down five times how well do you
think that bow is you two have a great
day
stop hitting the snooze button just
amusing your snooze on everything you're
snoozing on your dreams you're Susan on
your life stop it get up
back to the story so when you commit to
somebody else you more likely to follow
through I do this in my work out as an
example you know I commit to my wife
Nina and Shawn a personal trainer that
on Mondays and Wednesdays we're going to
work out I'm there at five o'clock and
we work out if I'm feeling tired if I'm
feeling you know stressed out lots of
work it's easy to say you know what I'm
not going to do that that's not
important but because they're going to
be there I'm going to be there right
when I come in on Mondays to work at
Toronto itself so here I work with Alex
and I work with Lily and they're going
to be here and they're expecting me to
be here we have a meeting set and I have
to go over stuff with them I have to
show up I'm not going to let them down
so whatever goal you have whatever you
want to stay more disciplined with try
to line up somebody to be with try to
line up a meeting try to line up the
schedule try to line up something with
somebody else because if you commit to
them you more likely to follow through
[Music]
good number five is have big wise and
little wise it's really important to
have a big wide to feel like what you're
doing is inspiring is motivating there's
a reason for you to get up and do work
if you feel like the work you're doing
is not important you're not going to say
disciplined on it if you feel like the
work you're doing is just pushing paper
and just filling out forms and grunt
work and administrative work it's
something you don't care about you're
not going to work hard if you feel your
work is meaningless you don't want to
work hard on that it's really hard to
say disciplined on it and so having a
big wide and know that the work that
you're doing matters means helping the
people you're working toward building a
better life for yourself whether you're
thinking about yourself and in that
ideal life you're trying to build
whether you think about your family your
community or the customers you're
serving having a big why helps you stay
motivated so for me I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs it's a big scary
ambitious goal right can I can I do it
is it possible the work I do has meaning
right I'm making these videos trying to
extend that goal it's not just oh I've
got to fill more videos as soon as I get
to that point I'm done on YouTube
if I dread the thought of coming in and
making videos or if it's just okay like
yeah whatever got to go make some videos
I'm done I have to move on to something
else you have to do meaningful work and
so thinking about what your big goal is
what your big vision is the change you
want to make and looking at that on a
regular basis keeping that in mind
and seeing how your work ties into you
accomplishing that big goal is really
important that's your big wire at the
same time you have your little wise
because the big white takes a long time
the Big Y is a lifetime goal right or a
year goal or five you like it it's out
there it's not going to happen today
it's not going to happen tomorrow
and so thinking long-term sometimes can
be very motivating but sometimes it can
also bring you down sometimes it can
also make you feel depressed like I'm
never going to hit that or Who am I to
hit that big goal I can't go out and do
these big things and so it doesn't
always serve you to the best of the can
and so that's why the little Y's are
really important and the little Y's are
the day-to-day little meanings that you
have in your business so for me is an
example the big Y's helping a billion
entrepreneurs the little Y are the
comments that you guys leave the little
Y's login and everyday and seeing that
you know Johnny really loves my video
and it made a big impact like your
comments mean a lot to me I look at them
every day it inspires me and inspires my
team and we know that yes we're helping
millions of people right we have
millions of views every month happening
on the channel and tied over 100 million
views on the channel it's numbers it's
hard to even imagine 100 million people
watching these videos but then to know
that this one person liked it and
appreciated it and talked about the
impact that it had those day to day
interactions are really important when I
was first getting started up in this
business of helping entrepreneurs I
would find this huge spike of enjoyment
when I did I did speaking engagements
and I would speak and just feel so great
but it may be two weeks until my next
speaking gig and then in between I fell
down like I didn't have anything like
what I'm not getting any feedback I
don't know that my work is meaningful or
contributing and so I would make a
PowerPoint file that I would watch every
morning and in it I would include some
of the feedback from the people who are
in my sessions some of the complimentary
things that people had to say for me to
feel like yeah like the work I do is
meaningful that matters and it's a
little why it's not solving a big
problem it's helping one person with one
thing they had in their business so I
think that combination feeling like
you're doing something important on a
big scale and also knowing that the work
do you do today is touching one person's
life and have an impact
it's easier much easier to say
discipline than on tack tip number six
is have a designated workplace this is
really important for entrepreneurs who
are working from home it can be hard
when you have all the comforts of your
home to float in between and try to work
from the kitchen and work in the couch
and work from your bedroom or whatever
it is that you work it can be hard to
stay on task it's easy to get distracted
by oh what's in the fridge oh what's on
TV oh who's that calling oh the docking
CityWalk they're all of the little paths
that kind of come up and get you
distracted if you have an easy time
seeing focus then doesn't matter right
doesn't matter at all you're fine but
you're not watching this video because
you have a hard time seeing discipline
you want some tips and so I would
suggest having designated place to work
and also designated time so that you
know from 9 a.m. to 1 p.m. you're going
to work at this place
and maybe that's outside the home it
could be leaving it could be going to a
coffee shop or going to a library or
going to a place of business somewhere
that you're going to go out there and
work or could be designated spot and you
know you have a home office in the
garage that you're setting up and when
you're there you work and when you're
not there then you don't work and I
think that makes it easier for people
have a hard time staying disciplined you
create a routine that allows you to stay
disciplined so an example when Alex and
Lily both started working for me and
where I'm helping mentor and coach them
to become entrepreneurs
I give them options like you can either
work from home you can either work with
me you can work from TDS you can work
from my place you can follow me around
you can whatever you want to do whatever
works best for your schedule whatever
works best for your personality style
and if they want to be around me all the
time and that it helps going to keep
consistency and like show up here at 9
o'clock great if they want to work from
home or work from coffee shops great but
creating a schedule helps especially if
you're not the discipline kind of person
to know that you know Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday excited
whenever whatever it is you're working
put it in I have a designated place that
when I'm going here I'm focused I'm
shutting off all those attractions and
I'm working
[Music]
tip number seven is do something you
love and this is the tip that comes up
most often when I look at famous
entrepreneurs and how they achieve
success they did something that they
love if you are forcing yourself to do
something that you don't love you can
only do it for so long before you're
going to quit I want to give up I want
to move on something else because you
don't love it you know not every day is
amazing as an entrepreneur but you have
to actually enjoy doing the work where
if you sit down and you're doing the
work you you don't see it as much as
being disciplined to have to do it
because you actually enjoy doing it and
so a lot of people just set these big
goals for themselves and they'll do
whatever it takes to go and get there
but if they don't actually enjoy the
process of doing it they're never going
to actually go and achieve those goals
much more important is that the work
that you're doing is something that you
are passionate about there has to be
something in your business that you can
get lost in there has to be if
everything is just work to you you're
not going to make it like quit now and
go do something else that you can't get
lost in not every piece of your business
you're going to be able to get lost in
especially at the beginning because
you're doing everything you may not get
lost in the accounting of your business
maybe you love accounting and that's
great be an accountant but otherwise a
lot of people don't want to do the
accounting side or don't want to care
about their taxes and all that kind of
stuff it has to get done but there has
to be something in your business that
you can get lost in and forget what time
it is
and the more you're doing that kind of
work the more you're going to be able to
not just stay disciplined but achieve
your big goals and as soon as possible
I've been looking at how can I build a
team to be able to take away some of the
things that I don't like that I keep
getting you know drawn in by or keep
procrastinating and give that to
somebody else so I can focus on what I
can be great at so those are my seven
tips on how to stay more disappoint I'd
love to know what do you guys think what
was your favorite tip what are you going
to apply to your life or your business
immediately then I missing eight nine
ten that you want to add to the list
leave it down in the comments below
really curious to find out and if you're
commenting in the first couple hours you
have a chance to win one of two daily
prizes that we have going on if you want
to vote on the next top seven waves
video I should make check out the link
in the description you can go there give
us your suggestions and maybe you'll get
lucky I also want to give a quick shout
out to Maria Rodriguez we she kept TV
thank you so much reaching for picking
up a cup of
I booked your one word and posting it on
your Facebook I really really really
appreciate it and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
coffee